all right a terrible story out of the
Smithsonian Air and Space Museum in
Washington DC a group of Catholic School
students they were thrown out of the
museum during their visit for the
national March for Life and they were
thrown out for wearing hats that had a
pro-life message on them the message
read Rosary pro-life a mother of one of
the students is claiming that they were
asked to remove the hats or leave and
after explaining that the hats were used
to identify each other and keep the
group together as they were escorted
they threw them out of the the museum
the museum did release a statement
saying what happened is not in line with
their policy and that they provided
training to prevent this from ever
happening again and keep in mind the
Smithsonian receives over one billion of
your taxpayer dollars a year here with
reaction he's leading up the case for
the American Center for Law and Justice
uh he's their director Jordan Sekulow
and one of the students thrown out of
the museum Patrick Murphy uh welcome
both of you Patrick
thank you I'm fond of that name that's
my son's name uh okay tell us what
happened
yeah so
we got done with the March for Life and
we decided to go to the air and space
museum we walk in it's it's a breeze we
go through in 30 minutes we end up at
the flight Brothers Museum or the
exhibit and
at this time we're addressed by two
women in all black presumably security
guards and they tell us indirectly and
they say
all people wearing a pro-life hat take
it off
and immediately we're confused
so
one of the students with us he proceeds
to say
you know we use these hats for
identification purposes this is for our
group so the the two women they they
kind of blew us off and we we walked out
and after that we decided to sit against
the wall
and we were approached by a a large man
as we were walking out because we had to
catch our bus right and
he comes up to us rubbing his hands
together saying y'all are about to make
my day
with a with a massive smile on his face
wow and he tells us he's got reports
saying we we said no to taking our hats
off and we're in trouble for some for
some odd reason
and
one of the students repeats the talking
point saying it's used for
identification
and he wasn't having it I then said
yeah keep keep going
yeah uh I then said
this is a violation of our First
Amendment right this is a
government-funded building uh how how
are we paying for this with our taxes
and I'm not allowed to wear this hat
I've got to give you credit yeah I got
um just you said this is a neutral zone
wow he said it's a neutral zone and that
doesn't apply here and we were blown
away we were we we had almost no words
I'm running out of time Patrick I want
to hear about the legal side I don't
mean to interrupt you and I'm very proud
of you for what you did in your stood
your ground Jordan legally does the
statement mean anything to you and what
are you going to do and by the way I
want to help the aclj win this
absolutely so we're a legal action is
imminent we've already put them on
notice to save everything because in
that statement they said they did a
training afterwards we want to know Sean
about the training before and they
didn't apologize to these students they
picked on the wrong students as people
can tell from Patrick we're going to get
to the bottom of it because we suspect
now that we've gone public we're going
to hear from more people who attended
March for Life who may have been
harassed at other museums and told for
some reason you have to take your hat
off of course uh they would never do
that that's not the Smithsonian policy
you can wear what you want there we're
fighting back and if you need help
aclj.org we want to hear from you all
right and I'm going to try and help you
in this case and we'll follow it to the
end uh Jordan great to see you Patrick
great job we're proud of you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else